[Applause]
all right let's take in inventory
unemployment non-existent check GDP
soaring check trade imbalance addressed
check nuclear threat introduced check
terror seems at bay check things are
looking up
why is that
if only the flag had arms to hug him
back feels like a good run for everyone
it is satisfaction with the country's
direction has reached a 12-year high
while trust in the mainstream media
drops to another low which could be why
the press has gone nuttier than an
elephant's diarrhea thank you thank you
that means it works for as it becomes
harder to deny something is working the
harder the media works to show something
is wrong so how do you smear America as
the Third Reich when it's not you lie
take Time magazine's cover this weeping
young girl became the media's poster
child for evil Trump's separation policy
but turns out she was with her mother
the whole time and her mom according to
dad took the child without telling him
now maybe your husband's bad I don't
know but I do know the media spread this
photo like a common cold just to keep
the evil alive meanwhile a feverish dolt
is coming for you if you vote for Trump
then you the voter you not Donald Trump
or standing at the BART border like
Nazis go you hear you hear and I think
we now have to flip it and it's a given
the evilness of Donald Trump but if you
vote you can no longer separate yourself
that's the next step everyone's a Nazi
now remember once you brand someone as
evil that allows for any or all behavior
you can show up the appeals at people's
homes because they're Nazis you can
threaten their kids because they're
Nazis
you can shoot congressmen because
they're Nazis funny that people shouting
Nazi do a great job impersonating them
if Donny Deutsch got any dumber he'd be
- Donny Deutsche's
because what he's mad about actually
happened before Trump the only change is
the guy in office Brooke Baldwin a rare
exception she got it right here's a
question for Democrats so many people in
this country are certainly outraged by
the cages and the thermal blankets and
the facilities housing these kids you
know they were all there in 2014 under
President Obama and my question to you
senator Baldwin is did you speak up
against them then you know on the on
this issue that we get into a moment
where we're making progress and then
when it when it stalls we turn around
I don't I don't think those were words
talk about a deer in the headlights that
Senator she just got mugged by the truth
in broad daylight so people now care
about the problem because it's Trump
good imagine if you had four more years
of some Democrat the human trafficking
that happened under Obama would still be
largely ignored it's true this abuse
happened while he was president even the
liberal website Snopes agrees but then
the press forgot that they covered it
because amnesia won't interrupt their
anti Trump tantrum so now Trump owns it
while trying to stop it and solve a
greater problem fact long-term fixes
have short-term setbacks adults get this
children never do and by children I mean
the media they're outrage is
unaccompanied by an adult solution we
know separating kids from parents that's
bad
leaving kids with traffickers that's
worse but I applaud those for waking up
to an issue they slept through under
Obama but Trump is succeeding and that's
their nightmare and even if Trump
compromises it's not enough in their
game the goalpost is on wheels here's
the current liberal opinion split up a
family temporarily you're a Nazi keep
the family together
you're also a Nazi but as for a solution
they freeze they don't need solutions
all they need are feelings here's a
former Obama official explaining how to
solve the immigration problem I wish
that I could bake a cake made out of
rainbows and smiles and we'd all be
happy she doesn't even go here do you
even go to this school no I just have a
lot of feelings it's all you need so the
left called Trump Hitler as Trump
handles North Korea trade jobs tarik
cetera that's the opposite of Hitler
he's a Gandhi an orange Gandhi
which is why the left is losing it the
latest of course is Peter Fonda mm-hmm
[Music]
yeah he's lost his motorcycle and his
marbles
this brain-dead basket case suggested
kidnapping and assaulting Donald Trump's
child what did I say before deemed
someone evil and you can do anything to
him and so the liberal manifesto has
been boiled down to two words a few
actually that's one letter and a word
but instead of professional suicide
Fonda has a movie coming out what Rose
Anton was zilch compared to this the
double standard thrives but it's not
just Fonda every celebrity they're all
dull conformist they think alike talk
alike at times they even walk alike here
they are on the red carpet
[Music]
[Applause]
no wonder they hate Trump he's a bigger
star he's more entertaining what would
you rather watch Sarah Sanders reducing
Jim Acosta to a puddle or Peter Fonda
tried to eat peas it's all I can take
but it's not about kids really it's
about 2020 and a willingness to cleave a
country over it
luckily America gets it a new poll has a
large majority believing the media is
inherently biased as optimism in the
country grows and as more people reject
the mainstream media journalists get
furious like Mean Girls uninvited to the
prom hence the mental chaos the threats
the Trump's son shoutouts to Hitler
tweeted pictures of death camps the
world's crumbling it began when Trump
was elected when Paul Krugman and his
ilk then predicted of course economic
collapse wrong again you jackasses the
economy is on fire which is the only
reason you can afford therapy
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest he has
more punchlines than a high school dance
writer and comedian Joe DeVito see so
sharper parents never gave her balloons
she's attorney Emily cope on yo National
Review reporter cat Tim and there is no
deep end in his swimming pool former WWE
was superstar massive sidekick Cyrus all
right Joe we know this is a tough
subject nobody wants to separate kids
what is lurking you well I think that
Senator missed a perfect opportunity
that's when you pretend your microphone
and earpiece don't work yes and you
don't just start something like if you
believe Trump is that bad then you don't
need to make fake photographs and you
don't need to repurpose photographs
right so four years ago it's a serious
issue and it should be treated seriously
instead of ignoring it the way the
people who had the reins of power for
the past eight years did it's not going
to be easy and there's going to be a lot
of suffering but I think what pisses off
the left the most is the idea that there
are people who want to come to the
United States of their own volition if
that means that the United States is not
the worst racist hellhole for non-white
people then their whole value system
gets exploded mmm that is an interesting
and very perceptive
thought you would I can't all right
you are the legal minds and I want to
ask you isn't is is Trump's sin
is trying to enforce laws and he'll
enforce a law if they change the law
right isn't that kind of how he is or
right that's exactly what's happening is
that he's trying to enforce the law but
he's running into the same conundrum
that Obama did which is essentially if
you please the masses then you're not
enforcing the law and if you enforce the
law then people are up in arms and I
think this issue is it's an iceberg and
the reality of our southern border and
the nine border sectors of it is that
it's not just about the drug cartels as
being these linchpins it's the messaging
first of all that's been oversimplified
by both sides and also we have to think
about what's pushing and driving these
people so desperately to our borders and
what is the pull factors that we have on
our side attracting them which includes
now catch and release and under the
former administration so I think the the
journalists that are doing the best work
they're people like Brandon Darby and
our iboga doe they're amazing because
they're not subscribing to that
messaging and they're really committing
to the fact that it's actually diplomacy
which is where we need to put our
efforts and that there's a lot of
there's a lot more people involved in
these cartels that are financers and
bankers and attorneys in these places
that that they are far more powerful
than the actual cartel heads but again
messaging just reduces it so how are we
to actually combat these Central
American pull factors and push factors
if we don't actually know the whole
picture mmm Emily your smartest stuff
this week
[Applause]
I feel bike ain't working I'm not
following Rodman is going to Honduras -
no no but I we were talking earlier it's
like it seems like the left got this is
Christmas for them you finally got one
yeah but they don't know what to do with
it right like a dog chasing the tires oh
my god him we may just fumble it away
cuz they just don't know how to play
their hand right right right
they overplay the hand yeah it was a bad
week for Trump when he does well we have
to say good job mr. president and when
he has a bad we're gonna say hey pulled
it back the plumage didn't handle it
right everybody kind of went into
business for themselves they said
whatever they wanted to say and because
it's an ugly thing but here in the stage
this is something that on the social
media I kind of got into it this week
was like when if some of this audience
has their children in the car with them
and they get pulled over for misdemeanor
and they owe to jail their kids go to
the system right like being arrested and
committing a crime is a rough ugly thing
it affects a lot of people and your
children if they're with you yes if
you're choosing to break the law they go
to the system yeah I understand the
reasons why you're coming to this
country I get it I grew up in California
I was around a lot of immigrants that
were coming into one person awesome and
for the most part for the most part they
were there to work raise their families
like you know and they worked hard okay
so I kind of have big there's also that
bad element and we have to be able to
screen because even if you let in five
hundred great hard-working soon-to-be
American citizens and one of them's a
mass murderer that's one too many
yeah and we have to screen we have to
vet and we have to do those things
[Applause]
that you think it's what do you think
this is going with the constant nazi
hitler comparisons I mean is this ever
gonna end
or is it where's it going I did not like
the separation policy not a fan glad
that it's not a thing anymore although I
really just genuinely don't understand
how it's like Nazi Germany yeah I don't
get how that's even a comparison so I'm
convinced that a lot of people maybe
just don't know what Nazi Germany is
that's a good point yeah maybe I think
it's just kind of spreads like wildfire
like they hear one person say it and
they're like you know they realize that
what they have to do to fit in with all
their buddies is agree that it's Nazi
Germany yes so that way everybody you
know other else you're gonna think that
you're a jerk so everyone just keeps
repeating it without ever actually
really explaining it mm-hmm
well if you believe being a Nazi means
being in favor of school vouchers you've
given yourself a wide range of people
you can call a Nazi yeah if you just
include anyone who doesn't agree with
you vociferous Lee as a Nazi that's how
they get away with it it's completely
illogical you know I think you're a Nazi
but you know yeah the ironic conclusion
here and I know I gotta go Trump gave a
lot of these cynical hypocrites the
wherewithal to do their job now this is
a real problem that reporters are now
going after only because it's under
Trump they're actually care about the
kids now so it's actually thank you
Trump for making reporters care
once again about children